does money buy happiness if you agree
smash thumbs up if you say absolutely
not smash thumbs down
and if you liked today's episode
subscribe to the channel so let's get
right into it there's a few things we're
going to look at
one the correlation between the income
you make and the level of happiness that
you have two
we will look at a study that harvard did
it's like a hundred year study
that they did tracking 268 people
from 19 i think 38 it's an 80-year study
from 1938
one of them was a president john f
kennedy and every year they followed up
with them to see if they were happy
and what made them happy and at the end
they figured out what was the most
important thing
that made these people happy some of
them became schizophrenia someone became
alcoholics some of them committed
suicide
some of them became lawyers doctors
attorneys millionaires billionaires and
obviously one of them president
it'll be interesting to see what you
think brings
happiness now let's first take a look at
income if money
buys happiness this is a great article
written here
by visual capitalist i highly recommend
you go visit their website
and i wrote it here does money buy
happiness
and the number shows that at around 75
to 80 000
it used to be 75 where you went to the
happier side
now it's eighty thousand dollars and it
just shows if you make
fifteen thousand dollars a year your
standard deviation
from mean response is you're about point
three four
less likely to be happy at fifteen
thousand dollars then it goes a little
bit happier
as you go up if you notice this thing
here until you get to 80.
at about 80 your expenses are covered
for the most part
you are having an okay life you're not
stressed out you don't have a lot of
things you're worried about you're doing
okay for yourself
but then guess what happens when you get
to six figure uh oh you're a little bit
happier
when you get to 175.17
happier 400 000.35 625 625.38
and you can kind of get the idea there's
three things they talk about
on the bottom here why why does money
buy happen as the report warns that any
theories behind our happiness increase
with income
are purely speculative however it does
list a few possibilities increase
comfort
as someone earns more they may have the
ability to purchase things that we do
reduce suffering this is particularly
true when comparing low to moderate
incomes
larger incomes below 80 000 you know
show
still showed a strong association with
reduced negative feelings
more control you get to kind of choose
what you want to do
so essentially money matters that's what
they're talking about in this article
now
over here this is the study we're
talking about
with harvard here's what the study looks
like
scientists began tracking the health of
268 harvard sophomores in 1938 during
the great depression
they hope the longitudinal internal
study would reveal clues to
leading healthy and happy lives so every
year they would follow up with them and
this has been going on now for 83 years
and it kind of gives you an idea what
some of these folks are by the way to
get into a little bit more
of the original harvard court recruited
as part of the grand study only 19 are
still alive
they're all in their mid 90s among the
original recruits were eventual
president john f kennedy long time
washington post editor
ben bradley women weren't in the
original study because the college
was still all male in 1938 eventually in
addition to that the scientists
expanded their search to include the
men's offspring who now
number 1300 and are in their 50s 60s to
find out how early life experiences
affect health
and aging over time some participants
who went on to become successful
businessmen doctors lawyers and others
ended up being schizophrenics alcoholics
but not on inevitable tracks so this is
what they came up with at the end of it
when they went through it the surprising
finding
is that our relationships and how happy
we are
in our relationships has powerful
influence on our health this is robert
waldinger director of the study a
psychiatrist
at massachusetts general hospital and a
professor of psychiatry
at harvard medical school said taking
care of your body is important
but tending to your relationship is
a form of form of self-care too
that i think i think is the revelation
look what he continues to say
over here the speaker when he gave this
ted talk this video i think's got 20
million views you have to see it
he says when we gather together
everything we knew about them
about at age 50 it wasn't their
middle-aged cholesterol level that
predicted how they were going to get to
grow old
it was how satisfied they were in their
relationship
the people who were the most satisfied
in their relationships at the age
50 were the healthiest at age 80. is
that not interesting by the way
how healthy your relationships are at 50
determine how
healthy you would be in your 80s and he
has a line that it says
robert this doctor here loneliness kills
it's as powerful as smoking
or alcoholism what a powerful quote
to say in regards to loneliness when the
study began
nobody cared about empathy or attachment
but the key
to healthy aging is relationships
relationships
and more relationships and on the bottom
here says something very interesting
it's easy to get isolated to get caught
up in work and not remembering oh
i haven't seen these friends in a long
time so i tried to pay more attention to
my relationships
than i used to what an interesting thing
to say so far we know two different
things we know one on one end
money can buy happiness when you make
over a certain amount of income
and number two is we know what people
value and live longer healthier happier
lives
the stronger the relationships by the
way when you look at money
the margin for happiness gets thinner
the more you make
meaning you live a different life when
you have a thousand dollars in a bank
versus you have a hundred thousand
dollars in a bank right because
thousand dollars in america you're
living paycheck to paycheck oh my gosh i
don't know how to pay the rent
i don't know what i'm going to do i got
to make the car payment family school
all this stuff
it's stressful you got a hundred
thousand dollars in a bank and you've
got a stream of income company making
800 grand a year
200 000 a year you're not really that
stressed out there's a big difference
between 100 grand
and a million dollars million dollars
you can do other investments you can be
patient you can have the
power of saying no but the difference
between a million two million not that
big of a difference
million 10 million big difference 10
million 100 million big difference
100 billion a billion big difference a
billion three billion probably not that
big of a difference
10 billion against 28 billion probably
not that big of a difference
the margin gets thinner if you're a
billionaire you everybody that's worth a
billion you're going to
you can afford to go to the highest most
expensive restaurant
go to the highest you know most
exclusive club hotel four seasons
travel the world jet cars house 50
million out of home
jewelry collection artwork you can have
all of that stuff
can you afford a sports team where
you're a majority owner at a billion
dollars today basketball probably not
five billion probably yes those are some
of the differentiators
but the margin for happiness is very
thin now there's a couple other things i
have for me
i think a part of happiness has to do
with culture and where you come from
currency
for happiness is different this is
forbes article from 2020
the article is from march 2020 march
20th 2020 top 20 happiest countries
filling at the top then denmark
switzerland is norway
netherlands sweden new zealand austria
luxembourg canada australia united
kingdom
israel costa rica ireland germany us at
18 spa czech republic belgium
the ten unhappiest places uh afghanistan
number one south sudan zimbabwe rwanda
central african
republic tanzania botswana yemen malawi
india right now so if you go to the
happiest what is the currency in some of
these countries
is it competition is it winning what is
it
so imagine a family you're raised in
whatever values and principles
your parents set for being successful if
it's
you get a college degree you're how
you're successful
if in that family you get a college
degree because all both your parents are
you know they have degrees you're
successful if they're athletes you
become an athletes except they play
guitar piano
music okay successful if they're
educators if they're doctors if they're
lawyers if they're business people if
they're politicians you see kind of what
happens
if you read books if you exercise in a
house if you pray if you go to church if
you're military if you're tough
if you can shoot hunt cook this is all
cultural right for currency for
happiness
i'm going to add a couple different
things from my own experiences to it
from what made me happy and what i've
experienced from other people that make
happy that i've witnessed myself
almost anybody i've met that's extremely
grateful they're some of the happiest
people i've met okay
you got music generates happiness you
got
experiences you can buy all the nice
cars in the world
or you can go to italy like for me i've
owned
ferraris lambos porsches rolls royce you
name them i've owned a lot of
exotic cars but i probably remember the
story
of me going to italy at marinello
when i went to the headquarters of
ferrari where the three-time ferrari
world champion
took me for a drive was dr teaching me
how to drive a
ferrari i was driving a 458 going 168
miles an hour i have the video until
today
it's pouring i'm flying
through the streets he's saying step on
it don't be afraid
step on it why are you scared step on it
i'm like this guy's crazy
he's absolutely crazy
just going right i will never forget
that story
that's an experience right exhilarating
when you see me at the end of this car
when i'm going
i'm laughing so loud it's not even funny
you feel the experience books
reading you close your eyes the
imagination takes you
and paints a picture it's a form of
being happy writing you're releasing
your thoughts it's like weight being
lifted off your back
when you're releasing it comedy humor a
great conversation
a great debate a great person to be
counted on
somebody who counts on you somebody
who's relying on you to make the right
decisions
that is a form of happiness that is a
form of fulfillment
playing games playing monopoly playing
romney playing spades
playing domino with your friends and you
going back and playing monopoly
there's a certain sense of happiness
that that creates
so this is where the guy at the end was
talking about how
uh you know i have to be a little bit
more aware to be around my friends
because
these relationships i value more today
than i did before so in closing i asked
this question before i even made the
episode on twitter i said does money buy
happiness i got a lot of different
response
one the guy said the following says i
don't know if it buys happiness but i've
never seen an unhappy person on a jet
ski
which was funny another one i saw was uh
it may not buy you happiness but the
happiest place on earth disneyland
will not let you in without money which
means hey if you want to go to the
happiest place on earth
you kind of need money which the premise
is you kind of need some money
to be able to do some of the things that
makes you
happy but at the same time if you want
to make money to put it in other
people's spaces
i don't know if that's a form of
happiness it may work for you short term
midterm but it's not going to work long
term because eventually you're going to
realize the value of very very very
good relationships that help lift you up
and the greater the relationship that
helped you challenge to keep getting
better versus those that pull you down
the happier you are long-term because
you're on an environment that's
challenging you
to constantly be getting better with
that being said if you still say money
doesn't buy happiness
put thumbs down but if you say now money
does buy happiness smash that thumbs up
button
and regardless of it all if you enjoyed
this episode subscribe to the channel
got another video i want you to watch i
did four or five years ago titled
how to find great friends how to build
great friends if you've never seen this
video
click over here to go watch it thank you
everybody bye bye bye bye